there are nine worlds in Norse mythology
these worlds are held in the branches
and roots of the wild tree in Drasil
today we take a closer look at these
worlds and the gods and beans that
inhabit them as God is the fortress home
of the gods ruled by Odin the leader of
the Aesir tribe both Valhalla and Falk
venire are located in Asgard
were the honored dead go if they are
chosen making as God the closest thing
to a heaven in Norse mythology as God is
divided into many rooms including
Valhalla
the home of Odin flood hime the realm
with all and braid the Blake the home of
Baal dear each God of importance had
their own Palace within as God as God is
connected to Midgard through the Rainbow
Bridge otherwise known as the Bifrost
and is the only way in and out there is
not much known about vanaheim as it is
not mentioned to the extent that as God
is vanaheim was sired by Nord
the god of the sea and his wife's God II
the home of the Vania tribe who many
consider to be the clan of lesser gods
the vana tribe consists of gods who were
often associated of fertility and nature
the room is full of vast forests fields
and plains
it also contains ruins of huge castles
and mountain size Citadel's known as the
abandoned city of veneer the war between
vanaheim and as God raged for many years
until failure married Odin
merging their people together an
achievement peace
Alfheim is the homework of the light
elves they are said to be as beautiful
and luminous as the Sun so we can
imagine that their homeworld is one of
light and beauty the elves do not take
part in any of the described events in
Norse myths and not much is known about
their home world other than it is the
palace of the god Freya
Midgard the land of humans as its
namesake suggests it is the middle land
of the nine worlds below as God the
realm of gods and goddesses and above
the underworld mid God shares its
borders of Jotunheim
the land of giants there is a fortress
wall made from the eyebrows of yamir
that covers the entire realm to protect
from attacks from the Giants the serpent
jörmungandr
encircles Midgard and the wilderness at
its borders as well as the serpent there
were giants who dwell in the sea waiting
for those who are unlucky enough to
cross their paths slaughter him often
shown as the home of the Dark Elves and
the dwarfs although in some texts the
dwarfs have their own realm called nida
Valley the dwarves are master Smith's
and craftsmen who live beneath ground it
is thought that svartalfheim in need of
the lid contain a network of complex
subterranean mines and forges the
dwarves were known for their work on
precious metals and they would often
build exquisite halls for themselves
there are many who believe that because
need of a lair is not part of the nine
worlds that neither Valley and svatah
line are in fact the same place this
would make the dwarves and the Dark
Elves the same creature Jotunheim the
homeworld of the Giants and neighboring
world to Midgard often seen as the vast
and mighty wilderness that surrounds the
more civilized world of Midgard
the dwelling place of the Giants
Jotunheim is often described as having
deep dark forests and mountain peaks
where the winter never eases its grip it
is a grim and inhospitable landscape
where the most fierce Giants in Norse
mythology came from Muspelheim one of
the two primordial worlds involved in
both creation and the Ragnarok it is the
land of fire and heat and is seen to be
the opposite to nil fan hyn the fire
giants earth defends this land and is
believed to be impossible to any
foreigner the demons of this land would
eventually march on Asgard led by Surt
himself nymph hime the other half of the
primordial worlds play in its equal part
in creation and the opposite to
Muspelheim it is a cold and dark place
covered in mist of I see caverns
scattered across the land
many consider nil fame and helheim
to be a similar place as evil men would
have to pass through near home before
they reached Hell Helheim often referred
to as nil fan hime or hell it is the
land of the dead those who are not
honorable in their death or banished by
Odin was sent to Helheim it is ruled by
Loki's daughter hell which one would
assume is where the name originated from
it is a lifeless land and its gates are
guarded by the wolf gone there is no
definitive answer but there is overlap
between the realms of Helheim and
Niflheim
there is much discuss when mention in
the nine worlds of Norse mythology this
was a quick overview but I look forward
to more detailed explanations in future
videos if you've enjoyed this video then
please go ahead and leave it a like
consider subscribing if folklore
mythology is something that interests
you if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained